hey guys welcome to another installment
of Harry Potter theory in this video we're
going to be discussing Severus Snape,
Professor Quirrell, Lord Voldemort and the
Sorcerer's Stone, now if we go back to
the Sorcerer's Stone you'll remember
that it was quirrells first year
teaching as the Defense Against the Dark
Arts professor his posting in this
position was questionable given his
incompetency and meek demeanor Snape
immediately gives Quirrell a hard time
and he's not discreet about it, even the
students notice suspecting that Snape is
just after quirrell's job we later find
out that Voldemort was possessing quirrell's
body and that his head was hiding in
quirrell's turban, what this means is that
wherever Quirrell was Voldemort was as
well because of this it should be safe
to assume that whatever conversations
quirrel had, Voldemort would have been
able to overhear Snape who openly
disliked Quirrell cornered him more than
once
first the night that quirrell let the
troll in and next on the night that
Harry broke into the restricted section
Snape says the following to quirrell
while pushing him up against the wall
you don't want me as your enemy Quirrell
to which Quirrell responds what do you
mean you know perfectly well what I mean
replies Snape we'll have another little
chat soon when you've had time to decide
where your loyalties lie
he continues essentially what Snape is
doing here is threatening quirrell and
pressuring him into declaring his
loyalty to Dumbledore, by doing this
Snape clearly revealed to quirrell that
he himself is loyal to Dumbledore, so if
he did this in front of Quirrell and
Voldemort overheard, which he must have, then
why didn't Voldemort further question
Snapes loyalty later on, additionally I
found it interesting that Voldemort
never attempted to contact Snape during
the Philosopher's Stone Snape didn't
even know that Voldemort was around and
this is interesting given that Snape was
once one of the most powerful Death
Eaters and one of Voldemort's loyal
followers later on Snape plays the part
of a double agent and shows allegiance
to whoever he is surrounded by but in
the Philosopher's Stone
he's quite clearly and quite
openly loyal to Dumbledore so why
wouldn't vote Mort kill Snape as soon as
he was physically able or at least have
Quirrell attempt to kill him the answer
to this question lies later on in the
franchise, in snapes own words in the
half-blood Prince- I think you next
wanted to know he pressed on a little
more loudly for Bellatrix showed every
sign of interrupting why I stood between
the Dark Lord and the Sorcerer's Stone
that is easily answered he did not know
whether he could trust me he thought
like you that I had turned from faithful
Death Eater to Dumbledores stooge, he was
in a pitiable condition very weak
sharing the body of a mediocre wizard he
did not dare reveal himself to a former
ally if that ally might turn him over to
Dumbledore or the ministry I deeply
regret that he did not trust me, he would
have returned to power three years
sooner as it was I saw only greedy and
unworthy Quirrell attempting to steal
the stone and I admit I did all I could
to thwart him and that's it for this
video I hope that answers the question
for some of you guys who may have been
wondering the same thing
until next time you're a wizard Harry